foreign
[Music]
books today we are checking out the new
Nvidia GeForce RTX 4080 and I no longer
need to specify that this is the 16
gigabyte model as there is only one RTX
4080 the unlaunched 12 gigabyte version
will no doubt still exist but it'll be
called something else like the RTX 4070
TI not the RTX 4080 so that in itself is
a good thing the bad news of course
being that the 4080 still costs at least
twelve hundred dollars US that's a
massive 71 increase over the RTX 3080s
MSRP though of course Nvidia would
probably rather you forgot that that was
everything and instead focus on the 1200
3080 TI a product that I called
pointless an obvious money grab
so it's gonna be interesting of course
the market has changed a lot since then
so it'll be interesting to see what the
RTX 4080 has to offer there is a lot to
talk about this review plenty of
benchmarks to check out but I think
first we will touch on the
specifications and take a bit of a look
at the Nvidia Foundation model before we
get into all those blue bar graphs and
of course I do have quite a few partner
card models so we've got the MSI
superimax the Asus tough gaming and a
pmy card with an awfully long name but
we'll get to all of that shortly uh
let's first yeah look at those specs the
RTX 4080 is based on the ad-103 Silicon
which measures
378.6 millimeters squared and that's a
massive 38 reduction compared to what we
see with ad 102 used by the 4090.
naturally this means a huge 40 reduction
in transistors though the 4080 still
packs 62 more transistors than the 3090
TI given those figures I imagine it will
come as no surprise allows two to learn
that the 4080 has 41 fuel recruiter
cores than the 4090 the memory bus width
has been reduced by 33 and there's 11
percent less L2 cash as for core clocks
there is little difference between the
40 90 and 4080 we're talking about
2505 megahertz versus 2520 megahertz for
the Boost clocks so a slight advantage
to the 4090 the 4080 though has been
awarded faster 22.4 gigabits per second
gddr6x memory so a seven percent
increase there from the 40 90. though
the smaller 256-bit wide memory bus
means the overall memory bandwidth has
been cut down by 29 from 1008 gigabytes
per second to
717 gigabytes per second now Nvidia
claims a total Graphics power rating of
320 Watts for the RTX 4080 and that's
the same rating given to the 3080.
though the maximum GPU temperature has
been slightly downgraded from 93 degrees
to 90 degrees the minimum power supply
require is 750 watts and for testing
I'll be using an 850 watt unit now in
terms I've designed the foundation 4080
is identical to that of the 4090 at
least externally the only difference
that we can account for at this point in
time is the weight the 4080 Fe model is
three percent lighter obviously there
are some physical changes Under the Skin
I imagine power delivery has been a
little bit cut down the memory
configuration has changed there's less
memory chips and of course the GPU die
is smaller so it's very possible Nvidia
made some changes to the cooling but we
don't have time to tear the card down
for this review point is though they
physically look like the same product
this means the RTX 48 is still using the
controversial 16 pin at 12 or vhpwr
power connector
now a lot has been said about this
connector over the past month but what
the real story is what's actually going
on well in our opinion it is still
unknown at this point so we're not going
to feed into that story that that drama
at this point in time we believe there
is a lot more investigation that needs
to be done before drawing any real
conclusions what I will say is that a
single PCI 5.0 power connector can
deliver up to 600 watts and previously
that would require four eight pin power
connectors however you won't need a pcie
5.0 compliant power supply as RTX 4080s
come with a three times eight pin to
single 16 pin adapter similar to the
three times eight pin to 16 pin model
supplied by the 3090 TI's and apart from
the increase in cause we also have the
inclusion of fourth generation tensor
cores and third generation RT cores the
GeForce 40 series also introduces DLS S3
a feature that at least for now is
exclusive to the GeForce 40 series now
since we last tested in video is DLS S3
technology not a lot has changed aside
from the launch of a few more games
supporting DLS S3 our investigation at
the launch of the RTX 4090 is still the
best place for a comprehensive breakdown
of the tech and it largely performs in
the same manner on the RTX 4080 Nvidia
are aware of the issues we brought up
and are working on a few fixes for
things such as the broken UI elements
and transitions that they'll let us know
when these updates have been rolled out
and of course we will then promptly
revisit DLS S3 as for our general
thoughts on the technology DLS S3 does
have some benefit but it's of a more
limited nature compared to dlss2 Gamers
will benefit most from DLS S3's frame
generation technology when games are
already being run at a good frame rate
somewhere around 100 FPS before DLS S3
frame generation is enabled with DLS S3
then boosting the fps to around 180 to
200 FPS this provides better visual
smoothness for those with high refresh
rate displays and works quite well under
these conditions that hides visual
artifacts and the latency Pro problems
we mentioned they're minimized it can
work okay below this sort of frame rate
but it depends on the type of game and
how sensitive you are to things like
latency and artifacts we wouldn't though
recommend it for gaming below 120 FPS
basically it's a niche feature that adds
to nvidia's strong feature set but it
isn't something we'd specifically pay
extra to access at least not right now
so for this review I won't be including
any DLS S3 benchmarks as I said Tim will
revisit the technology once Nvidia
addresses the issues uncovered in our
initial investigation as a side note
though I have heard from some reviewers
who were only able to acquire a review
sample from Nvidia if they promised to
include dlss3 benchmarks in their review
which is fair enough as dlss3 is a
technology that requires investigation
but it really does need to be
investigated properly and the FPS
benchmarks really do need to be
accompanied by detailed image quality
and latency analysis another big issue
with dlss3 benchmarks is reporting frame
generation as an FPS metric for example
120 FPS using dlss3 frame generation
it's not really 120 FPS it's the
smoothness of 120 FPS with the input of
roughly half that frame rate plus
potentially a few graphical issues and
this is a serious issue for Benchmark
graphs and I would suggest any reviewer
benchmarking with frame generation
enabled they should report the numbers
as 120 dlss 3.0 FPS as an example
now for testing all gpus we have done so
at the official clock specifications so
no Factory overclocking the CPU used is
the ryzen 7 5800x3d with 32 gigabytes of
dual rank dual Channel ddr4 3200 cell 14
memory on the MSI MPG x570s carbon Max
Wi-Fi motherboard in total I've tested
13 games at 1440p and 4K so let's get
into the data
first up we have Watchdogs Legion and at
1440p we are CPU limited with these
higher end gpus still the data is
relevant for anyone with a 5800x 3D or a
CPU that's slower but for unrestrained
GPU performance let's move to 4K here we
get a much better idea of what the RTX
4080 is actually capable of 110 FPS on
average meant it was 22 percent slower
than the RTX 490 but also 25 faster than
the 6950 XT 42 faster than the 3080 TI
at 57 faster than the 3080. so some
pretty impressive generational
improvements there
Rainbow Six extraction isn't as CPU
Limited at 1440p as what we saw in
watchdog's Legion and as a result the
4080 was 40 faster than the 6950x10 30
faster than the 3090 TI that said it was
just 18 slow in the 40 90. so let's see
if that margin grows at 4K
as expected it does is here the 4080 was
20 slower than the 4090 though it did
still manage an impressive 158 FPS at 4K
and that made it 45 faster than the 3080
TI 56 faster than the 3080 and 61 faster
than the 6950 XT
now for testing Far Cry 6 we don't use
the built-in Benchmark rather we're
showing actual in-game performance
unsurprisingly the data is very CPU
limited 1440p and as a result the 4080
was just three percent slower than the
4090 with 181 FPS on average
moving to 4K shifts the primary
performance limitation onto the GPU and
now the 4080 is seen trailing the 4090
by a 21 margin with 130 FPS on average
that also made it just seven percent
faster than the rate on rx6950 XT which
does very well in this title but then it
was 29 faster than the RTX 3080 TI and
40 faster than the RTX 3080
next up we have Assassin's Creed
Valhalla and at 1440p the RTX 4080 was
good for 161 FPS which saw a trail the
4090 by a 12 margin while beating the
6950 XT by a 12 margin but let's move on
to 4K to see how those margins change
interestingly even at 4K the 4080 was
just 14 slow in the 49 and just 15 fast
and the 6950 XT the Radeon GPU is helped
Along by excellent support for resizable
bar so overall a bit of a disappointing
result here for the new GeForce GPU
the RTX 4090 really impressed us
previously in Hunt Showdown and while
the 4080 isn't as impressive it's still
well ahead of previous generation Parts
trailing the 4090 by a 22 margin but
leading the 6950 XT by a 34 margin the
3080 TI by a 37 margin and the 3080 by a
massive 58 margin
then we see that the 4K margins are much
the same here the 4080 was 24 slower
than the 4090 with 121 FPS on average
making it 29 faster than the 6950 XT and
44 faster than the 3080. as usual we're
seeing a clear pattern emerge here this
time testing the outer Worlds at 1440p
saw the 4080 just 21 Soul on the 490 but
22 fast in the 3090 TI 27 faster than
the 3080 TI 34 faster than the 6950x10 a
massive 46 faster than the 3080. the
margins remain much the same at 4K
though here there are some odd changes
we see that the 4080 was good for 119
FPS making it 25 slow on the 40 90 but
just 13 faster than the 3090 TI despite
still beating the 3080 TI by a 28 margin
so the 39 DCI does seem to be doing a
little bit better here than you'd
probably expect
Hitman 3 is a very CPU intensive game
and admittedly the 5800x 3D it isn't the
fastest CPU here in fact not even close
with the release of Zen 4 and Raptor
lake so I will be updating all of our
GPU data soon though at this point I'll
probably wait until early next year to
see what gets announced at CES before
investing weeks upon weeks to update all
of our GPU data
all of that said CPU limitations aren't
an issue at the 4K resolution and here
we see that the 4080 is the expected 22
slow in the 40 90 with 142 FPS on
average this did make it 26 faster than
the 6950 XT and 69 faster than the RTX
3080.
the 5800x 3D does perform really well in
Horizon zero Dawn and yet despite that
we still run into a hard CPU bottleneck
with the new GeForce 40 series as both
the 4080 and 40 90 were limited to just
over 210 FPS
jumping up to 4K once again removes any
CPU performance limitations and delivers
the expected margins as we've seen time
and time again the 4080 is a little over
20 slow in the 40 90 and we're seeing a
24 margin in this example
next up we have F1 2021 and at 1440p the
4080 was 16 slower the 40 90 with 206
FPS on average and that meant it was 34
faster than the 3090 TI and a massive 48
faster than the 6950 XT
then at 4K we see predictable margins as
now the 4080 is 25 slower than the 40 90
and 52 faster than the 6950 XT so really
it was just the 4090 that was running
into system limitations at the lower
1440p resolution
moving on to cyberpunk 2077 we find that
the 4080 was good for 128 FPS on average
with the 5800x 3D pairing which made it
12 slower than the 40 90 and just 17
faster than the 6950 XT increase the
resolution of 4K though that does see
fairly typical margins restored and now
the 4080 is 23 slower than the 40 90 but
33 faster than the 3080 TI and almost 50
percent faster than the original 3080.
Dying Light to stay human isn't a very
CPU demanding game and as a result we're
not CPU Limited at 1440p allowing the
RTX 480 to churn out 151 FPS on average
resulting in a typical 21 deficit to the
4090 that margin did grow slightly to 25
for Kane interestingly the 4080 was just
11 faster than the 650 XT due to an
unusually strong result here for the
Radeon GPU
the second last game tested is Halo
infinite and here we are clearly running
into a CPU bottleneck at 1440p as the
4080 was just six percent slower than
the 4090 but impressively still 42
faster than the 390 show and 51 faster
than the 650 XT only at 4K the 48 is now
only 32 faster than the 39 HDI which is
still a large margin but smaller than
the 42 margin seen at 1440p it's also
Now 23 slower than the 4090.
the last game tested is shadow of the
Tomb Raider and at 1440p the 4080
rendered an impressive 206 FPS and that
meant it was 13 slower than the 40 90
but 35 percent faster than the 6950 XT
then bumping up the resolution to 4K
still saw an average of 116 FPS though
this did make the 40 80 28 slower than
the 40 90 so that's one of the bigger
margins we've seen disappointingly it
was also only 23 faster the 3090 TI and
33 fast on the 6950 XT
okay so here's a look at the 13-game
average data the RTX 4080 produced 189
FPS on average making it 12 slower than
the 40 90 at 1440p in our testing it was
also only 24 fast in the 650 XT and 25
faster than the 3090 TI while we're
looking at a 38 boost over the 3080 TI
and 51 over the 3080. then at 4K where
the CPU bottleneck is completely removed
the 4080 was on average 23 slow in the
40 90 making the flagship Ada level H
GPU 30 faster the 4080 was also 22 fast
and the 3090 TI 31 faster than 6950 XT
37 faster than the 3080gi and 52 faster
than the 3080. also just because I know
many of you want to see the 1080p data
here's the 13-game average of course we
were almost always quite heavily CPU
Limited in this testing and that's why
the 4080 is just 16 faster than 39 TI
and only 7 slower than the 40 90. now
time for a look at Ray tracing and
upscaling performance starting with f122
at 1440p the 4080 and 490 are limited to
around 300 FPS with rtfx disabled but
enabling RT plus dlss resulted in
roughly the same level of performance
with 181 FPS for the 4080 and 189 FPS
for the 4090 and this made the 4080 just
12 percent faster than the 3090 TI then
with upscaling disabled the 4080 was 32
slower than the 40 90 and 22 percent
faster than the 3090 Chi while it
crushed the 6950 XT by a massive 83
margin now moving to 4K does help to
remove the CPU bottleneck and now the
4080 is 27 slower than the 4090 before
the rtfx are even enabled the margin
actually grew to 36 with rt plus dlss
enabled and then 38 with just RT enabled
with no upscaling when compared to the
390 TI the 4080 was 19 faster and then
100 faster than the 6 950 XT yikes
next up we have Watchdogs Legion and
here the 4080 and 49 he delivered
similar performance under all three test
conditions the 3090 TI was also able to
match the 4080 with dlss enabled as this
appears to be the limit of what the
5800x 3D can render with rt enabled so
moving to 4K does give us a much better
picture of where the 4080 stands and
here it is 27 slower than the 4090 with
rt plus dlss enabled and 26 faster than
the 3090 TI it was also a massive 115
faster than the 6950 XT which was using
FSR
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy is also
quite CPU Limited at 1440p of course the
performance overall is Stellar with
frame rates up around 200 FPS without RT
enabled but it also doesn't show us how
the 4080 truly Stacks up so let's move
to 4K right so at the 4K resolution the
4080 is 22 slower than the 4090 with rt
plus dlss enabled and 21 faster than the
3090 TI it was also a massive 81 faster
than the 6950 XT which was again using
FSR
moving on to the Dying Light 2 results
we see that at 1440p the 4080 was 26
slower than the 40 90 we're comparing
the RT plus dlss results this also made
it 47 faster than 3090 TI which is a
huge margin and we saw previously at the
GeForce 40 series does very well in this
title it's also a similar story at 4K
here the 4080 was 31 slow in the 40 90
but 46 faster than the 3090 TI and a
massive 100 faster than the 6950 XT
which was again using FSR
finally the last Ray tracing dlss
Benchmark that I have for you looks at
performance in cyberpunk 2077. here the
4080 rendered 102 FPS at 1440p with rt
plus dlss enabled making it just 10
slower than the 40 90 and 23 faster than
the 3090 TI at 4K those margins change
and now the 4080 is 27 slower than the
4090 when both are running rtfx with
upscaling enabled this also saw the 4080
defeat the 3090 TI by a 26 margin and
the 6950 XT by an incredible 115 margin
okay so what about total system power
consumption well the 4080 is remarkably
good here as we see in Dying Light 2
pushing total usage to 404 Watts which
is similar to that of the 3070 TI and
6800 XT so very manageable indeed it's
also a 23 reduction in total system
usage when compared to the 4090 power
usage did creep up a little bit in do
maternal hitting 471 watts and now the
4080 finds itself is situated between
the 3080 and 3090 but it did still
reduce total system usage by 22 when
compared to the 4090 then finally in
Hitman 3 we find more of the same power
usage is still lower than that of the
3090 and is really comparable to the
3080. so given the performance just seen
I'd say the RTX 48 is very efficient but
let's go and lock the frame rate for an
interesting look at Power efficiency
now with all four gpus tested here
locked to 90 FPS we get to see just how
power efficient the RTX 4080 is the 4090
really did impress in this test
previously and we see that the smaller
ad103 die is even more efficient
dropping power usage by around six
percent this means under the same
operating conditions the 4080 uses half
as much power as the RTX 3090 TI super
impressive stuff
now finally it's time for our cost per
frame analysis and we'll start with MSRP
pricing just to get a feeling of where
pricing over the life of each product
should have been starting with the cost
per frame based on the 1440p data we see
the 4080 slots in between the 3072i and
6900 XT neither of which were
particularly Great Value in their
respective series than when compared to
the 3080 price to Performance has a
regressed by 13 and at 27 when compared
to the Radeon RX 6800 XT still Nvidia
would be quick to point out that when
compared to the 3080 TI the 4080 is a
substantial Improvement in value
reducing the cost per frame here by 28
the 4K MSRP data is a little more
favorable but even so the 4080 is still
13 more costly per frame than the 3080
so in that sense even when based on MSRP
pricing it's not great value but when
compared to the 4090 it is a slight
improvement though I suspect many of you
who are entertaining spending 1200
fellows us in a graphics card would
probably just opt to go the full hog
with the 4090 the bigger issue with the
4080 in value can be seen when
discussing the current GPU market and in
this graph using the 1440p data it slips
to one of the weakest options you can
purchase right now only roughly matching
the terrible value RTX 3080 TI but given
how CPU limited much of the 1440p
results were let's make our final value
analysis based on the 4K data
so here we are the cost per frame
results based on the 4K data using
current retail pricing here the 4080 is
again slightly better value than the
4090 reducing the cost per frame by a
mere three percent a value-wise the 4880
is also comparable to the 3080 TI at its
current asking price of 860 dollars
which frankly isn't great given that
that makes it 11 more costly per frame
than the 3080 which is worse value than
amd's Radeon RX 6900 XT and world's
worst value than the 6800 XT of course
none of those gpus are even remotely in
the same league as the 4080 when it
comes to Performance so it'll be very
interesting to see what rdna3 can do
here
now let's take a look at the three
partner models that I have on hand
before checking out the operating
behavior of each model along with
nvidia's Fe version starting with msi's
RTX 4080 supremax this one's pretty
simple if you've seen our RTX 4090
supremax review as it's the exact same
cooler the 4080 version though does
weigh just 60 grams less and like the Fe
model that difference can be attributed
to the smaller GPU fewer memory chips
cut down power delivery and fewer
components on the PCB in general still
at 2 360 grams this thing is still very
heavy and of course Very massive given
the RTX 390 TI version of the Supreme X
is smaller the size and weight of the
RTX 4080 is very much unnecessary but it
seems as though it was just easier for
nvidia's partners to mass produce these
monstrosities and stick them on all
current generation high-end graphics
cards so regardless of how you feel
about these comically large graphics
cards it appears they're here to stay
anyway weight the Supreme X is an
excellent quality model it looks great
and as we're about to see it works very
well
then we have the Asus RTX 4080 tough
gaming and this appears to be a carbon
copy of the 4090 that we've already
reviewed I'm not saying that it's made
of paper though quite the opposite in
fact like the 49 this thing is wrapped
in metal with very few plastic elements
to speak of however while it does appear
to be the same cooler there are some
noteworthy changes here which will
reduce the manufacturing costs whereas
the 4090 tough gaming tip the scales at
2 320 grams the 4080 version is 17
lighter at 1 920 grams the bulk of that
difference can be attributed to the
cooler which is 308 grams lighter at a
total weight of 772 grams now whereas
the 4090 version made use of eight
nickel plated copper heat pipes to
contact with the large Vapor chamber the
4080 does away with the vapor chamber
entirely and although there are still
eight heat pipes just two of them
measure eight millimeters in diameter
with the rest of the six millimeter
variety the 4090 on the other hand
packed five eight millimeter heat pipes
and this allowed for a significantly
larger contact patch with the base plate
speaking of the base plate the 4080
version only makes contact with the GPU
while an aluminum spreader contacts the
memory chips with the aid of a few
thermal pads of course
then over on the PCB there are fewer
power delivery components the much
smaller GPU and just eight memory chips
opposed to the Dozen you'll find on the
4090 then we have the PNY RTX 4080 which
wins the award for the absolute worst
name are you ready for this one guys
it's the PNY RTX 4080 accelerate so XLR8
gaming virto epic Dash X so I think
we're just going to call the the ver2 or
virto anyway this is a fairly standard
looking RTX 4080 it measures 71
millimeters wide so it will take up four
slots it's 332 millimeters long and it
stands 136 millimeters tall from the
pcie connector all up it weighs 1860
grams making it just three percent
lighter than the RTX 4090 version
that said there are some real design
changes between the 4080 and 4090
versions despite them looking very
similar overall the 4090 has a
reinforcing structural bracket that runs
the perimeter of the card whereas the
4080 does away with that bracket
entirely for a modified heatsink design
so an interesting difference there then
there's the standard changes to the PCB
but since I haven't had a chance to
review the 4090 model yet I can't
compare them all that closely just yet
the only issue I have with this model is
the lack of a dual bars feature which
for me is a bit of a deal breaker
especially at this price point anyway
with that I think we're going to take a
look at Thermals operating clocks and
Power
okay so here's a look at how nvidia's
Founders Edition operates after an hour
of Hitman 3 at the 4K resolution using
the maximum in-game quality settings
these temperatures were all recorded in
a 21 degree room installed inside an ATX
case with the doors closed the GPU
hotspot peaked at 78 degrees while the
memory reached 74 degrees and we saw an
average core clock frequency of 2760
megahertz a power drive 300 watts and a
fan speed of 1450 RPM so decent results
but nothing amazing
the MSI supremax results though are
remarkably similar with the hotspot
temperature also hitting 78 degrees
though the memory was slightly cooler at
72 degrees we're also looking at a
similar operating frequency at 2745
megahertz with a power draw of 308 Watts
the fans were spinning slower at 1200
RPM but overall a very similar result to
nvidia's Fe model
then we have the Asus tough gaming and
this card spun its fans a bit faster at
1550 RPM which limited the peak hotspot
temperature to 77 degrees and the memory
to 72 degrees so basically the same
result as the Supreme X and Fe models
the average power drill was higher at
314 watts and this allowed for a
slightly higher sustained
2775 megahertz operating frequency
then finally we have the PNY verto and
as you guessed it basically the same
results here we have a hotspot
temperature of 78 degrees though the
memory was considerably cooler at 62
degrees so that's an impressive result
the average power draw was also fairly
standard at 312 watts and we have the
typical 2730 megahertz core clock
frequency all of this was achieved at a
1300 RPM fan speed so really the
differentiating factors here are the
physical card design as in the
appearance and of course the price
overall I'm coming away from this review
of nvidia's new GeForce RTX 48 here with
kind of mixed feelings I guess from a
performance standpoint it is clearly a
very impressive product delivering 111
FPS on average at 4K across the 13 games
we tested so that's a 20 to 30 increase
over previous generation flagships and
that's of course great and all except
for the fact that it's priced like a
previous generation Flagship at 20 more
expensive than the 600 XT and just
25 less than the already massively
overpriced RTX 3090 and let's not even
bother with the MSRP of the 3090 ti so
while I absolutely love the performance
and features of the RTX 4080 it's hard
to get too excited when I know you guys
have to stomach the 1200 us asking price
not only that but we have the awkwardly
named Radeon RX 7900 XTX which will
arrive next month at an MSRP of a
thousand dollars us and it should
comfortably beat the RTX 4080 at least
in terms of rasterization performance
there's still of course the issue of
Road tracing which is now a very
important performance metric and while
FSR continues to improve so too does
dlss and it is still the superior
upscaling technology as a side note if
Nvidia were to only increase the 80
series MSRP by 29 I know only this would
have seen the 4080 coming in at 900 U.S
so 200 more than the 3080 and although
that's still a very big price hike the
4080 would have been excellent value in
today's market and in fact it would be
the best value GeForce GPU on the market
matching the cost per frame of the 510
RX 6800
sadly though that is not to be because
Nvidia knows Gamers will pay 1200 us so
twelve hundred dollars U.S it is
still I think the point is it's
difficult to draw any real conclusions
until we've seen what the 700 XTX has to
offer only then can we properly evaluate
the value of the RTX 4080 so with that I
don't think there's much Point dragging
this reviewer any further we now know
exactly how the RTX 4080 performs but at
this point in time you clearly shouldn't
buy it not if you care about value
getting the most bang for your buck and
all of that and if you don't care about
value then the 4090 is probably the
better choice anyway anyway as I've said
given that the 4080s direct competitor
is landing next month there's a little
point in making any firm conclusions
here we'll just wait for the Radeon GPU
review to really conclude what we think
of the 4080. so with that if you enjoy
the video please do give it a like
subscribe for more content because there
is plenty more content coming and if
you'd like to become a harbor unboxed
Community member get some really cool
perks in return then we have float plane
patreon that'll get you access to
monthly live streams with Tim myself we
have one of those coming up shortly our
behind the scenes content our exclusive
Discord server great place to hang out
and tell myself we're all so active
there you can ping us ask us questions
all that sort of stuff and Q A's I think
I've said everything but anyway if
you're not interested in that that is
perfectly fine and I would like to thank
you for watching this video especially
if you made it all the way to the end
good stuff I'm your host Dave see you
next time
[Music]
foreign